[Music]
get that later good morning folks
okay just uh for your time of day I
suppose hi I'm Tom Melendez and this is
the next in a series of short videos
showing you how you can use ansible with
Google cloud platform if you saw our
first couple of videos you'll recall the
theme of these videos is that I'm a
DevOps engineer using ansible to manage
infrastructure for our satellite imagery
project earlier I received a text
letting me know about unexpected traffic
surged on our imagery website but we're
auto-scaling with Google cloud platform
so I can keep playing my game still
until va's here from Red Hat again
joining me to talk about how we're using
ansible to manage our infrastructure I
all Tom thanks for having me again can
you describe to set up and then I'll be
happy to walk us through the ansible
playbooks like we did last time sure
Google compute engine not only has VMs
like we saw in the last video but it
also has lots of networking capabilities
in this video we'll walk through Howard
using GCS HTTP load balancer to create a
globally accessible cross region
auto-scaling website running on managed
VMs all provisions with ansible I'm
going to kick off the provisioning
process and then hand it over to Dylan
to walk us through these tangible
playbooks you can watch our first video
if you need tips on setting up Google
cloud platform or ansible okay so while
that's running let's take a look at some
of the playbook shall we sure let me
open it up all right okay so now that
that's open it looks like we have a
playbook that execute commands from
localhost and include some variables
from various files like last time right
you can run this commands from anywhere
as long as you have the proper
credentials okay cool so first we're
creating a couple of managed instance
groups we set the name and zone as well
as the starting size and we're also
setting the instance template that
should be used in building these new
instances and then it looks like the
managed instance group also where you
configure the auto scaling policy is
here as well
yes okay so that's one of the greatest
features that I think are there
out scaling applications with Google
cloud platform can you tell us a little
bit more about auto scaling and depth
okay
well with auto scaling you can have your
host scale up or down based on a policy
you configure the policy can be based on
things like CPU utilization or what
fraction of the load balancer
utilization the instance group should
handle you can even define policies
using custom metrics if those don't suit
you and details are in documentation
right right to keep it simple we went
with CPU utilization this policy
basically reads scale accordingly to
keep the CPU utilization on the machines
under 80 percent and that's it
GCP will scale up those instances for
you yes so the max number of instances
that you specify that's great
so I see we specified two management
subscrib seer with basically the same
configuration very true we want it to be
explicit here but one might consider
using a looping construct like with
items or with bits and then finally for
our managed instance group we have name
port specified yes those are where the
backend service will send the traffic
this great Segway so let's talk about
back-end services what is a back-end
service for basically a back-end service
is a collection of instance groups the
backend service lets the administrator
treat all of these instance groups as a
single entity in terms of serving
capability so what do you mean by that
well we've configured the manage
instance groups to scale up based on CPU
previously but really we haven't talked
about how much traffic we want them to
handle by grouping these instance groups
into a back-end service we can set
additional configuration as well as a
health check on the whole entity and
then you can have multiple back-end
services I imagine right right this lets
admins build out their desired
infrastructure placing groups of
instances where it makes sense for them
and determining how much traffic they
should handle wow this really seems
super powerful it is another powerful
and customizable feature is the URL map
which we have up next so now it looks
like all of the configuration here is
pretty minimal it looks like just giving
it a name and handling the back-end
service that we created what is you
I'll map for anyways you're right in
this case and for many applications
simple configuration such as this is
fine
in essence the URL map Maps the URL to a
back-end service we don't do it here but
you can route different paths to
different back-end services so for our
configuration the playbook is basically
saying map any URL to the default
back-end service right right next is a
target proxy which terminates the
connection from the client a route the
request to a URL map in this case we're
using an HTTP proxy so we could then
change that to an HTTP proxy and then
still use the same URL mount though
right correct in that case you would
also specify the SSL cert in addition to
a URL map and then finally create a
static IP address and a forwarding rule
right up until this point we filled out
the load balancing capability now we're
creating an IP address and mapping to
the proxies gotcha so when a client
makes a request of the IP address on
that port the proxy is going to handle
it yep and that's the entire
configuration for a global load balance
web application so cool not a whole lot
of configuration then how the
provisioning go it was done a lot sooner
than we were the load balancer was
created successfully great so how does
this look in the web console let's take
a look okay
opening up the dashboard then we click
on networking then load balancing let's
click on the advanced menu down at the
bottom here which gives us the component
breakdown that mirrors how we built it
up at ansible we see the global
forwarding rule and the IP address it
maps to under target proxies you see the
proxy name the type of proxy and the URL
map to apply clicking on backend
services we see our back-end service
let's click on that
hey cool traffic so we can see how much
is being served out of each instance
group here right I generated this
traffic with a bash one-liner using curl
one instance in our each east region one
in the West just to demonstrate the
grass interesting note that the user can
click right here and adjust the settings
that they like so but of course those
are going to be overwritten by the
playbook the next time because of the
desired state of the system yep of
course well that's it another quick
in-and-out video showing ansible
GCP thanks Dylan you're welcome Tom hey
it's been great showing viewers how to
use ansible with Google cloud platform
are you up for another one
I sure AM we've got more to show you
folks so we'll see you next time and
don't forget to check out all of our
ansible modules at the URL and
description below
[Music]